[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 29 juin voici
les titres de cette édition une centaine
de patrons de multinationales étrangères
reçu par emmanuel macron le quatrième
sommet choose france s'est tenue hier au
château de versailles l'objectif attirer
les investissements à 22 projets ont été
annoncés pour 3,5 milliards d'euros nous
parlerons également de l'attractivité du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
avec alexandra rosetti vice présidente
de l'agglomération autour de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines à vélo
c'est l'action entamée hier par la
députée de la majorité présidentielle
aurore bergé elle va parcourir en dix
jours 240 km au travers de 50 et une
commune la parlementaire souhaite mettre
en valeur le patrimoine du sud yvelines
et les acteurs locaux du monde culturel
et puis la crise sanitaire a fait
grandir l' envie de consommer local pour
faciliter la mise en relation entre
producteurs et habitant la chambre
d'agriculture d'ile-de-france a lancé
une carte interactive
en quelques clics il est possible de
trouver des légumes des oeufs de la
viande autour de chez soi mais avant de
développer ces titres on débute ce
journal à poissy malgré le retour
compliqué du beau temps le plan canicule
a déjà été activée dans cette maison de
retraite
au niveau national le plan est active
depuis la début juin comment
fonctionne-t-il éléments de réponse avec
juliette prigent et patrick jacques de
dixmude à la fiche à l'entrée de la
maison de retraite de poissy donne le
ton ici les fortes chaleurs sont
redoutés pour l'été et le plan canicule
a déjà été activée depuis le 1er juin
l'objectif éviter aux résidents de se
déshydrater
nous sommes très vigilants sur les les
températures donc il ya un contrôle de
température plusieurs fois par jour et
on adapte bien sûr notre fonctionnement
en fonction notamment
les cerner les volets tirés tirer les
rideaux fermés les fenêtres pour que la
chaleur ne rentre pas et préserver au
maximum les espaces dans lesquels ils
évoluent au quotidien la salle de
restaurant et climatisées tout comme les
chambres des résidents qui dispose
également de ventilateurs et la
nourriture est adapté avec plus de
fruits et de produits frais quant aux
soignants les effectuent des tours
d'hydratation il propose un verre d'eau
toutes les heures au centquatre
résidents de l'établissement
plan canicule c'est surtout à essayer de
motiver les résidents à boire à
s'hydrater un proto se couvrir et 500
personnes âgées donc on a des soucis
avec leur thermogénèse parce qu'ils
connaissent pas est sombre il n'oublie
qu'il fait chaud donc seulement il ya
beaucoup qui se couvrent un peu trop
donc ont déjà demandé aux familles de
leur porter des vêtements clairs
maintenant quand on soupe et puis
ensuite on les crée en les hydratant
plus possible la maison de retraite
ouvre aussi ses portes aux aînés des
alentours
eux aussi peuvent venir profiter des
installations mises en place et se
rafraîchir
comme chaque semaine le point sur
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 et sur la
campagne de vaccination dans les
yvelines
le recul du virus se confirme pour le
moment malgré l'émergence du variant
delta en france depuis le 18 juin le
taux d'incidence nombre de nouveaux
contaminée pour 100000 habitants et le
taux de test positif baisse encore
amélioration également du côté des
hôpitaux 33,6 pour cent des lits de
réanimation sont occupés en
ile-de-france recul de 10 points en une
semaine
32 patients de moins également dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois depuis le 21 juin et
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire le
kobe de 19 et 1842 victimes dans les
hôpitaux du département
en ce qui concerne la vaccination elle
progresse dans les yvelines mais moins
vite que les semaines précédentes au 27
juin 643 1305 personnes avaient reçu une
première injection soit 24 milles de
plus en une semaine auparavant la
progression était plutôt de l'ordre de
50 milles par semaine mais le nombre de
personnes totalement vacciner à lui
progressé + soit + 63 milles et depuis
le 20 juin dans les yvelines 396 1722
personnes ont désormais reçu deux doses
de vaccin
[Musique]
c'est une tradition désormais depuis le
début du quinquennat d' emmanuel macron
la quatrième édition du sommet et
schultz france s'est tenue au château de
versailles ce lundi 28 juin cet
événement a réuni près de 150 dirigeants
de grands groupes étrangers français
l'occasion pour le président de la
république et le gouvernement est de
promouvoir l'attractivité économique de
la france les détails avec nicolas
landry ils étaient plus d'une centaine
de dirigeants internationaux des têtes
d'affiché comme stéphane bancel pdg de
moderna groupes pharmaceutiques ou
encore jamie dimon pdg de la banque
américaine jp morgan
tous venus au sommet tous france avec un
intérêt pour l'attractivité économique
de la france aujourd'hui le plan de
relance est décaissé très rapidement
nous avons déjà engagé plus d'un tiers
du plan de relance
et puis il ya une deuxième série de
questions qui d'ailleurs présage
d'autres investissements dans les mois à
venir c'est sur la décarbonation et sur
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
pour cette quatrième édition du sommet
de shoes france 22 projets
d'investissements ont été annoncée pour
un montant de 3,5 milliards d'euros et
7000 emplois à la clé c'est le cas du
groupe pharmaceutique allemand merck
présent sur 11 sites en france comme
grand groupe mondial du secteur
pharmaceutique
nous avons décidé de continuer à
investir dans les capacités de
croissance avec du matériel plus
performant pour soutenir la production
et les clients autour du monde nous
avons deux fantastiques collaboration
avec des universités les instituts
scientifiques parce que nous avons un
partenariat de longue date avec le
gouvernement français
la principale annoncé l'ouverture dans
le nord de la france d'une usine de
production de batteries pour les
véhicules électriques avec de possibles
répercussions pour le territoire des
yvelines avec l'annoncé de
l'investissement chinois notamment en
matière de batteries
on sait bien que c'est une filière qui
est fondamental pour la filière auto et
qui est une pierre très structurante ici
dans les yvelines
et donc c'est une excellente nouvelle
effectivement de voir que on a
des investissements qui vont aussi in
fine et irriguer le territoire de son
côté la région ile de france mène aussi
une politique pour favoriser
l'attractivité du territoire francilien
nous avons identifié des sites et
notamment des friches industrielles qui
sont prêtes à l'emploi et ses sites
prête à l'emploi nous allons les mettre
à la disposition des patrons nous avons
aussi mis en place une équipe qui est
chargé d'accueillir y compris les
impatriés en 2020 la france reste le
pays le plus attractif d'europe avec 985
projets d'investissement on va parler
justement attractivité avec mon invité
en plaçant le curseur sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines 17 mille
entreprises 145 mille emplois c'est le
deuxième pôle économique et de l'ouest
parisien bonsoir alexandra rosetti pense
à vous êtes vice présidente de
l'agglomération en charge du
développement économique et de
l'attractivité j'ajoute également vous
êtes maire de la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux alors tous france
un sommet j'imagine forcément suivi avec
attention qui s'est déroulé en plus tout
près au château de versailles avec 22
projets annoncés 3 5 milliards d'euros
d'investissement en france
est ce que le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines pourrait en profiter
qu'est-ce que vous avez l'espoir que ça
puisse profiter à ce territoire saint
quentinois
oui bien sûr parce que d'abord nous on a
un travail avec un partenariat avec tous
paris région et les parts depuis bien
longtemps en étroite collaboration
donc tous paris région c'est l'agent 102
au régional de promotion et
d'attractivité internationale
et puis paris saclay pour l'accueil des
entreprises étrangères
et on constate même si on constate une
stabilité des investissements
internationaux à paris les départements
de grande couronne dont les il peut par
contre enregistre une hausse de 40%
donc ça montre ça témoigne de la volonté
de la région et d'autres choses paris
région de rééquilibrer l'implantation de
projets internationaux dans les
territoires franciliens n'ont parlé dans
un instant de sa stabilisation et même
de cette hausse
dans l'est dans les départements de la
grande couronne francilienne à 50
minutes je le disais il ya dix sept
mille entreprises 145 mille emplois et
ce qu'on sait à peu près la part
d'entreprises étrangères dans les 17000
qui sont présentes à saint quentin
alors encore plus de 250 entreprises à
capitaux internationaux
donc ça représente à peu près 20% des
emplois dans notre principale filière
cellier willis est historiquement une
terre d'accueil d'entreprises
internationales et qui viennent
d'ailleurs majoritairement des états
unis d'allemagne et du japon et donc
vous le disais la tendance est plutôt à
la hausse sur les investissements sur
sur ces derniers mois oui et on a
enregistré une hausse donc on est plutôt
encouragé et puis on a des filières qui
de toute façon sont implantés sur notre
territoire depuis longtemps comme
filière automobile nissan europe
mercedes benz et puis bien sûr pris
récemment bmw oui justement avec
peut-être de tendance on voit des grands
groupes vous parliez de bmw qui a fait
construire son nouveau siège
justement à montigny le bretonneux donc
une volonté de rester sur le territoire
saint quentinois a contrario on peut
avoir aussi des exemples permaswage une
entreprise américaine dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique on a suivi le dossier
avec attention qui avait peut-être le
projet de délocaliser son son site qui
est installé aux clayes sous bois
ça veut dire que il ya quand même deux
tendances des grands groupes qui
souhaitent rester peut-être d'autres
entreprises qui pourraient partir avec
on le sait des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire qui pourrait se faire
ressentir aussi dans les prochaines
années ah oui forcément ça serait trop
beau si tout le monde ne voulait que
venir il ya souvent des problèmes qui
peuvent être liés à l'immobilier
d'entreprise a des preuves d' espaces
verts est ce que ce qu'ils ont l'espace
suffisant
où est ce qu'ils cherchent des espaces
plus petit ça dépend des situations
et puis aussi parfois des problèmes
aussi pour attirer de jeunes cadres de
jeunes gens
deux jeunes ingénieurs pardon qui est
parfois trop souvent préfèrent rester
sur paris
parce qu'ils ont un mode de vie sur
paris qui leur convient et se déplacer
de paris à saint quentin en yvelines
s'est pas tout à fait le même projet de
vie il ya des problèmes des problèmes
des classements surtout une fois qu'ils
ont quitté la gare voyez donc tous ces
éléments là font que certaines
entreprises peuvent aussi bien sûr
tenter de changer de territoire en vous
parliez du travail de collaboration avec
notamment paris tu aux régions qui l
agence de promotion d'attractivité
internationale de la région ile de
france
comment expliquer que ce territoire
saint quentinois est attractive soit
attractif parliez tout à l'heure aussi
de paris-saclay forcément saint quentin
en yvelines est aussi intégré dans paris
saclay il ya la proximité avec paris
peut-être qui peut être une source de
d'explication comment comment on peut
l'expliquer justement pas je pense qu'on
a on est on est complémentaire avec
paris saclay et sur saint quentin en
yvelines il ya dynamique qui ne se
dément pas on voit bien d'ailleurs tous
les nouveaux projets qui sont en cours
de rénovation de restructuration ou de
reconstruction
en particulier je pense au projet autour
de la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
par exemple vous avez de très beaux
bâtiments qui sont en train de sortir de
terre et d'être rénovée pour qu'il ya
toujours cette dynamique de l'immobilier
d'entreprise qui est extrêmement
importante
et puis ensuite on a un accompagnement
de nos entreprises sur saint quentin qui
et qui à mon avis extrêmement
remarquable et donc qui le rend
attractif alors en particulier bien sûr
dans le domaine de la création
d'entreprise mais n'est pas uniquement
donc et puis le cadre de vie quand même
assez exceptionnel sur les communes de
50 ans minimes qui permettent de dater
ray et de loger sur place différents
types de différents types de salariés du
cadre jusqu'à ouvrier dans l'industrie
par exemple
donc je pense que tous aient tous ces
éléments militent à bout se rendre aux
autres territoires très attractif avec
régulièrement aussi des événements
internationaux on pense forcément à la
ryder cup qui a eu lieu
le territoire en 2018 est ce que saint
quentin en yvelines profite justement de
ces événements internationaux on sait
qu'ils allaient gio aussi qui arrivent
en 2024 justement pour faire la
promotion de ce territoire essayer
d'attirer toujours plus d'entreprises
étrangères mais parce qu'on va quand
même accueillir sur quatre sites six
épreuves des jeux olympiques
donc ça va contribuer comme ça a été le
cas on vu le nombre de personnes qui ont
pu voir la ryder cup forcément des
événements mondiaux de cette ampleur
contribuent à la nature à la notoriété
de notre territoire
c'est clair une dernière question est ce
qu'il ya des gros projets
d'investissements court dans les cartons
vous ça reste secret défense pour le
moment secret défense peut-être mais pas
particulièrement de faire on travaille
beaucoup sur ont donné des identités à
différents secteurs
on est beaucoup axeon saxe de plus en
plus sur la cybersécurité on développe
des partenariats justement avec les
écoles parce que ça c'est un sujet
absolument majeur des années qui
viennent donc il faut pouvoir développer
des et puis j'ai d'ailleurs à l'arrivée
d'entreprises étrangères sur ce domaine
ou parce qu'on parle de plus en plus de
souveraineté française sur ce domaine de
la cybersécurité est ce que vous êtes
ouvert à saint quentin en yvelines a
aussi accueillir pour ce pôle
cybersécurité des grandes entreprises
étrangères ah oui nous on est ouvert
nous verra tout évidemment mais c'est
vrai que nos propres entreprises sont
déjà bien sûr très axé sur ce sujet et
ce qui manque aujourd'hui de ce qu'ils
en disent c'est vraiment le compétence
développement de compétences donc
comment montrer à nos à nos jeunes à nos
étudiants que c'est un domaine
extrêmement riche porter est donc ça
c'est aussi l'un des enjeux qu'on a pris
à bras le corps il ya un gros travail
partenarial entre saint quentin entre
l'université et puis juste que
j'ajouterais aussi de pas oublier qu'on
a des startups à saint quentin on a un
incubateur et qu'on a lancé une nouvelle
dynamique également pour tirer les
sparkle internationale sur notre
territoire
déjà cette année nous avons
intégrer un laboratoire japonais une
entreprise italienne et puis nous
développons également donc signé un
premier protocole d'accord avec le pays
de galles avec tex parker weeds et donc
ça c'est un organisme qui soutient des
industries technologiques et numérique
au pays de galles et l'angleterre évoque
l'idée c'est d'abord des visites
réciproques des échanges pour avoir un
développement mutuel de différents
programmes
merci avec sandra rosetti d'abord être
avec nous merci à vous et je rappelle
vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge du
développement économique et de
l'attractivité du territoire
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également les nouvelles
conditions d'utilisation de l'aérodrome
de toussus le noble fixé par arrêté
ministériel est publié depuis le 20 juin
au journal officiel
à retenir l'interdiction des tours de
piste des avions de certaines catégories
particulièrement bruyante le week end et
jours fériés d'avril à septembre sur les
mêmes tranches l'interdiction pour les
hélicoptères des vols d'entraînement ou
des vols touristiques circulaire sans
escale ou avec escales de moins d'une
heure enfin l'interdiction des vols
touristiques toujours pour les
hélicoptères de moins de vingt minutes
des conditions qui viennent s'ajouter à
d'autres dispositions prises en mars
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble qui est
l'objet de tensions entre riverains et
usagers vous l'avez vu sur ces images
une manifestation s'était même tenu sur
place à la mi juin
la députée des yvelines aurore bergé a
débuté hier le tour de la 10e
circonscription du département à vélo là
où elle est élue
la parlementaire profite de la fin de
session parlementaire justement pour
aller à la rencontre de ceux qui font la
culture dans le sud yvelines et ce
pendant 10 jours les précisions avec ce
sujet de juliette prigent le village de
réseau donne le départ du circo à vélo
pendant dix jours sur son deux-roues
assistance électrique la députée aurore
bergé va parcourir 240 km à travers
cinquante et une commune de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
le but mettre en valeur le patrimoine et
les acteurs locaux du monde culturel
l'idée c'est aussi de redécouvrir ce qui
existe à côté de chez nous tout le
patrimoine de proximité tous les
artistes qui existe parce que parfois ce
qui est juste à côté
c'est un peu ce qu'on ignore parce qu'on
va le chercher plus loin de l'évasion
alors qu'en fait on a toutes les
ressources ici donc c'était aussi les
mettre en valeur tout simplement
première étape de ce tour à quelques
mètres du départ l'ancienne maison de
robert doisneau
l'occasion pour le maire de faire
connaître l'histoire commune entre le
célèbre photographe du 20e siècle et son
village doisneau représente pour les
habitants et nouveau moi mes anciens
habitants quelque chose de familial
s'est ouvert et les habitants de la
commune connaissait la famille doisneau
les enfants doisneau puisqu'il ses deux
filles donc à toutes les impasses et qui
pour essayer de maintenir quelques
minutes de pause et c'est reparti fin du
tour prévue dans dix jours à montfort
l'amaury le 7 juillet prochain
une carte interactive pour trouver en
quelques clics ses légumes c'est eux sa
viande autour de son lieu d'habitation
elle a été créée par la chambre
d'agriculture d'île de france pour
faciliter la mise en relation entre
producteurs et consommateurs
une centaine d'exploitations y est
actuellement référencés le reportage
d'astrid bergère et de bérangère
bourgoin fini de parcourir de nombreux
sites internet pour trouver des
producteurs locaux
la chambre d'agriculture d'île de france
a mis en place une carte interactive
pour faciliter la mise en relation avec
les consommateurs dans la bulle t en
puissance le souhait de consommer local
et une des remarques vous avez
régulièrement et est que en fonction
chacun communiquer sur sa marque ou sur
son type de produits vous n'avez pas une
vision assez globale de la chose et donc
l'idée a été travaillé à pouvoir pouvoir
géolocaliser sur une carte avec des
filtres intéressant pour ce que l'on
recherche
voilà un maximum de produits franciliens
issus de nos fermes gratuite pour le
consommateur et pour le producteur
l'unique but de cette carte est la mise
en relation une aide bienvenue pour les
agriculteurs qui peine parfois à
communiquer sur la multitude de choix
qu'ils proposent
nous on a une exploitation donc de 13
hectares en maraîchage en arboriculture
donc on a une production assez
diversifiée du fait de nos modes de
commercialisation en direct
donc on a vraiment une très très large
gamme de production avec une centaine de
références différents en fruits et en
légumes des fruits et des légumes mais
aussi de la viande des pâtes des
des boissons les produits sont variés on
a une centaine de producteurs inscrits
aujourd'hui donc avec avec différentes
solutions pour le retrait à travers soit
1 h à la ferme directement soit dans des
magasins de producteurs où ils se
regroupent pour pouvoir échanger leurs
produits et de manière à simplifier la
tâche à port lay pour les consommateurs
sur le site des filtres sont disponibles
pour affiner la recherche par exemple en
termes de labels ou du type de retrait
des commandes
et puis un projet pour étudier la vision
des oiseaux afin de mieux comprendre
pourquoi ils ne perçoivent pas les
éoliennes son nom en quatre lettres map
il a été mené à l'espace rambouillet du
14 au 18 juin dernier explications avec
bérengère bonté le projet à lui dans de
nombreux parcs et en collaboration avec
les parcs éoliens à l'espace rambouillet
ces quatre espèces de rapaces qui ont
été étudiés dans le cadre du projet map
dont cet aigle blessé par une éolienne
on vient ici pour étudier certaines
espèces notamment l'aigle royal qu'on a
ici derrière pour essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce qui fait que les rapaces ne
voit pas les éoliennes et qu'est ce qui
fait qu'ils rentrent en collision avec
les élèves le principe est simple
l'oiseau est soumis à un test et ses
mouvements de tête sont étudiées pour
que les chercheurs puissent identifier
les contrastes ok ils réagissent c'est
un test qui est très simple qui est non
invasif on aime bien le préciser c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas de contraintes pour
l'oiseau l'oiseau est juste présenté
devant des écrans donc dans une boîte
transparente présenté devant des écrans
il ya huit écrans autour d'elle autour
de l'oiseau pardon migrants autour de
l'oiseau et on met un pattern qu'on
appelle un gros lifting qui est une
alternance de barres noires et de barbe
blanche et on le fait bouger soit vers
la gauche ou vers la droite
des études d'impact ainsi que des
systèmes de détection des oiseaux et
d'arrêt des éoliennes sont mis en place
par les parcs éoliens les premières
études qui ont été faites on entre et
que les oiseaux ont une capacité de
perception du contraste qui est à peu
près 10 fois inférieure à la nôtre
donc c'est vraiment très faibles donc si
on voit que ça se généralise chez la
plupart des oiseaux notamment les
réseaux qui sont concernés par les
collisions avec les éoliennes on pourra
dire que le contrat c'est certainement
un facteur qui fait que les oiseaux
rentrer en collision avec les éoliennes
et si c'est ça on pourra agir derrière
au terme de cette étude des solutions
seront envisagées pour pallier cette
mortalité comme par exemple le peindre
certaines pas l'éolienne en noir ou y
ajouter des motifs c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]